The media is tripping over a new study finding
that LSD may lower anxiety.
Get it?
Tripping?
I'm Cristen Conger of Stuff Mom Never Told
You in today for DNews.
The results of a Swiss study examining the
impact of LSD therapy on anxiety among terminally
ill cancer patients has attracted a swarm
of media attention even though it was too
small-scale to yield conclusive results.
Research on LSD has been largely shut down
in the United States ever since the psychedelic
drug became illegal in 1966.
But recently, researchers have begun taking
closer looks at the possible medical benefits
of banned drugs like LSD.
Take psilocybin, a hallucinogenic cousin to
LSD and the key ingredient in "magic mushrooms."
It has also been shown to have therapeutic
potential.
A 2010 study also conducted on a small group
of cancer patients suggested the psychedelic
compound may also ease anxiety, and a 2012
study examining MRI scans of people while
tripping on it found that it appears to calm
down brain areas associated with depression.
Considering that its street name is ecstasy,
it's not too surprising that the drug MDMA
might also assist with anxiety and post-traumatic
stress disorder, or PTSD.
A recently published study compared fMRI brain
scans of participants both on and off MDMA
and found that the drug seemed to make happy
memories happier and sad memories less sad.
The researchers suspect the pain-dampening
effect has to do with how MDMA lowers blood
flow to the brain's limbic system that helps
regulate our emotional reactions.
A lesser-known drug that's received attention
from the medical community is ayahuasca, a
psychedelic blend of plants developed by native
peoples of Amazonian Peru commonly associated
with spiritual enlightenment by those who've
taken it.
Ayahuasca ceremonies were also used in a 2013
study on substance abuse.
For the dozen study participants, taking ayahuasca
was correlated with greater long-term feelings
of hopefulness and improved quality of life.
Self-reported tobacco, alcohol and cocaine
use also diminished.
Marijuana habits, however, persisted -- which
brings us to the last drug on our list which
might not even be illegal, depending on where
you live.
Various studies have indicated that weed might
be helpful not only for pain management and
nausea suppression among chemotherapy patients,
but also for soothing anxiety, depression,
bipolar disorder.
Pot -- or the THC in pot, that is -- may even
be an effective treatment for autoimmune disorders
and multiple sclerosis.
But remember kids, many of these studies are
preliminary AND there also are negative side
effects to all of these drugs, hence them
being classified as controlled substances.
Do think illegal drugs could actually be "good"
for us?
Leave a comment down below and be sure to
check out my channel at youtube.com/stuffmomnevertoldyou.